warum sich so viele menschen so viele
auch von ihnen von politikern abwenden
schuld sind diese beiden
spitzenpolitiker schauen sie christine
lambrecht
verteidigungsministerin und rechts peter
feldmann frankfurts oberbürgermeister
wir haben ihn getauft als deutschlands
peinlichsten bürgermeister der vorwurf
an beide die nutzen ihr amt los aus die
eine die fliegt mit dem dienst delhi
nach sylt das wissen sie macht dort dann
schön urlaub und lässt vor allem auch
noch ihren sohn mit dem luftwaffen heli
gleich einen fliegen auf die
urlaubsinsel und der andere rechts der
hat den europapokal sieg von eintracht
frankfurt ja ganz schön schamlos
ausgenutzt um sich selbst zu inszenieren
er hat sich den pokal gekrallt nach dem
großen erfolg und hat ihn den spielern
und dem trainer einfach aus den händen
genommen die beiden haben noch etwas
gemeinsam die klammern sich anja am
christine lambrecht die heli affäre
versucht sie einfach auszusetzen aber
kann das klappen jetzt wird's
tatsächlich richtig eng für christine
lambrecht
das foto das deutschland seit wochen
aufregt alex lambrecht der sohn der
verteidigungsministerin er fliegt
luftwaffen heli nach sylt in den urlaub
mitgenommen von mama ministerin doch die
findet es völlig okay ich bin als
ministerin in der situation dass ich
sehr wenig zeit habe für privatleben und
insbesondere für den kontakt mit meinem
sohn und deswegen kann man diese
entscheidung in frage stellen dafür habe
ich auch verständnis ich bitte um
verständnis dafür dass es darum geht
eben auch den kontakt zum kind weiter
aufrecht zu halten aber wie gesagt ich
habe verständnis dafür wenn man das auch
kritisiert wirklich alles okay sie habe
sich an alle regeln gehalten schwert
lamprecht zeit gekommen rechtlich alles
sauber auch als ministerin als bürgerin
das alles was welche entscheidungen ich
treffe dann auch rechtlich völlig
korrekt sind das ist ja auch der fall
doch auch daran gibt es jetzt immer mehr
zweiter und das selbst bei den juristen
in lambrecht eigenen ministerium ein
hammer eine interne untersuchung der
rechtsabteilung des
verteidigungsministerium bewertet den
fall als kritisch lambrecht habe den
heli flug ganz offiziell als inhaberin
der befehls und kommandogewalt
gebucht damit hatte dieser flug hohe
priorität doch der haken durch diese art
der anmeldung habe der flug keine
privaten begleiter erlaubt rechtlich
also dann doch nicht alles sauber eine
ministerin die sich an ihr amt klammert
für die es jetzt aber noch enger wird
und herr zum studio bild live chef claus
strunz eine ministerin die sich an ihr
amt klammert klaus und jetzt umso fester
nochmal klammern muss weil selbst im
eigenen ministerium gesagt wird das ist
möglicherweise rechtlich noch nicht mal
rechtlich sauber endlich endlich endlich
merken wir etwas von der aufklärung im
eigenen ministerium dann das der fall
sozusagen nicht korrekt ist und dass das
will man wahrscheinlich am stammtisch
sagen wird zum himmel stinkt was da
passiert ist das ist ja jedem klar seit
wochen und christine lambrecht setzt
glaube ich auf die strategie der derzeit
gewinnung und des aussetzens deshalb
bisher ganz gut geklappt es ist
aufgekommen vor der nrw wahl da wird man
nicht entlassen damit es kein große
skandal gibt jetzt ist himmelfahrt dann
ist pfingsten und ich glaube nach
pfingsten wird sie denken sie die welt
ganz anders aus dann müssen wir heute
aber zu rufen liebe frau ministerin das
werden wir nicht zulassen und deshalb
ist es ganz wichtig dass diese
aufklärung jetzt läuft nach der es ja so
aussieht als habe sie nicht korrekt wie
sie es für sich selber in anspruch nimmt
und nicht komplett legal gehandelt es
geht ja bei der reise um die reise zu
ostern jetzt hast du schon gesagt jetzt
sind wir ein bisschen weiter nämlich
himmelfahrt wieder langes wochenende und
ich habe heute einfach mal gefragt im
verteidigungsministerium und gefragt
gibt es eigentlich wieder ein kurzurlaub
auf sylt und schau mal klaus was die
antwort ist aus dem
verteidigungsministerium also unsere
frage ganz klar machte die ministerin
wieder kurzurlaub jetzt oder hat die
dienstliche verpflichtungen jetzt über
dieses lange wochenende das ist die
antwort die bundesministerin der
verteidigung plant in den kommenden tage
bis zum kommenden sonntag
einschliesslich keine öffentlichen
termine fehlt das e keine öffentlichen
termine heißt nicht dass sie dienstlich
nicht im einsatz ist das hat man so ein
bisschen verschwurbelt zumindest können
wir aber nicht ausschließen dass der
dienst täglich noch mal zum einsatz
kommt gut also wenn sie hat noch mal am
dienstag irgendwie auf der urlaubsinsel
fliegt dann ist hier nicht zu helfen
vielleicht kann sie die tage nutzen um
noch mal darüber nachzudenken wer wohl
das foto gemacht hat von ihrem sohn im
juli das für mich eher die bis heute
nicht das ist für mich die verrückteste
frage von allem auch an unserem
berufsstand wir erhalten sie ja da
sozusagen in schach wir wollen wissen
wer hat dieses foto gemacht und wir
kriegen immer zur antwort das wisse
keiner also in einem bundeswehr
helikopter sitzen irgendwelche menschen
und machen fotos vom sohn der minister
noch niemand weiß werden dann wissen wir
ja angst und bangen wer sich das sonst
noch so ist heute nicht beantwortet
obwohl die fragen von uns kam und von
bundestagsabgeordneten weile auch also
ich hab es gab schon gesagt das ist ein
tag an dem wir wieder erleben warum sich
viele deutsche von den politikern
generell abwenden der fall lärm
lamprecht trägt dazu bei und auch der
fall peter feldmann trägt dazu bei das
ist der oberbürgermeister von frankfurt
noch immer noch der peinlichste
bürgermeister deutschland so haben wir
ihn getauft und das hat einmal mit dem
pokal zu tun den er sich gekrallt hat
von der eintracht frankfurt ii hat den
abgeräumt nach dem europapokalsieg und
der bürgermeister wollte den erfolg für
sich und hat sich den pokal einfach
gekrallt das hat aber auch zu tun mit
dem dienst flug nach sevilla hier sehen
sie diese zähne biss im pokal noch mal
mit dem dienst fünf in der lufthansa
nach sevilla zu dem pokalendspiel
da hat sich nämlich der
oberbürgermeister das mikrofon das
bordmikrofon genommen und hat dann diese
peinliche rede gehalten schafft
die papiere an sowohl vom bodenpersonal
und sanieren von den flugbegleiterinnen
die schauen am anfang erstmal außer
gefecht gesetzt haben meine damen so das
war es dann aber für feldmann jetzt
dritter zurück dachten viele dann ist er
vor die kameras gegangen am vormittag
unter das hier gesagt schauen sie
ja ich habe fehler gemacht und
dafür stehe ich zu recht in der kritik
ehrlich zu sein ich war selbst
erschrocken als
ich das video aus dem flieger gesehen ab
wie sie wissen bin ich habe zwei
wunderbare töchter ich tue alles dafür
dass es ihnen starke frauen werden auch
deshalb war es falsch mir tut es auch
leid dass beim eintracht empfang am
donnerstag der eindruck entstanden ist
sei um mich nicht um die mannschaft
gegangen die in siviglia wirklich etwas
sehr großes
etwas gigantisches geleistet hat
an diesem abend sind mir als überzeugten
eintracht-fan die gäule durchgegangen
also erst mal ich wollte dieses strom
sie bei mir im studio und jetzt muss der
rücktritt kommentieren die spd und mein
rücktritt gefordert
heute treffen sich vor informiert wird
aber jetzt jetzt soweit ich habe
verstanden dass ich den augen viele in
den vergangenen wochen nicht die
gebotene zurückhaltung an den tag gelegt
hat versagt und jetzt habe ich
beschlossen bis zum ende der sommerpause
auf repräsentative themen termine wahr
holzkirche und kaiser soll nahezu
vollständig zu verzichten
auch sonst wird man halt und üben und
die städtische medienarbeit zum einen
termin einstellen was keine
pressekonferenzen mehr das ist die
konsequenz betrifft pressekonferenzen
pressemitteilung und social media es ist
verrückt ich habe entsprechend du wirst
ist bis das ende des sommers dazu das
haupt angewiesen etwa erzählt sich zu
wissen welche themen vorantreiben und
denen man ziel und mein herz hängt den
ausbau der sozialen infrastruktur der
kostenlosen also raus da kommt nichts
mehr wo die begrenzung fanden dachten
klaus der tritt zurück und dann das der
zieht sich einfach nur zurück der sagt
ich trete nicht mag keine
pressekonferenzen mehr ich arbeite
einfach ein bisschen anders aber ich
bleibe also hat ja seine töchter zitiert
die starke frauen werden sollen ich
glaube meint auch die an die demokratie
glauben sollen an deren und anderen
repräsentanten
ich glaube wenn ich meiner tochter
diesen mann vor führe unter zusage der
hat da also den spielern den pokal
geklaut der hat sexistische bemerkungen
in flugzeugen gemacht und er ist unter
verdacht der vorteilsannahme in
frankfurt also in einen wirklichen
prozess verwickelt dann würde sie sagen
der kann auf keinen fall weitermachen
und das sagen auch glaube ich alle
bürger mit verstand nur er hat es nicht
verstanden das signalisiert ich halte
mich für wichtiger als mein amt und
meine stadt ich halte mich für wichtiger
als die die mich tragen für die ich da
bin das ist das absolut fatale signal
und im grunde ist er jetzt der vorzeige
politiker der politikverdrossenheit ganz
kurz was lernen wir an diesem tag über
politiker und verantwortung sie nehmen
sich zu wichtig und uns zu unwichtig und
das wird sich am ende recht danke an
bild live chef claus strunz